[Music]
let's go to kayla in denver colorado hey
kayla what's going on
hey it's good to talk to you it is even
better to talk to you what's up
okay so um oh that was a big deep breath
big breath it's it's been a lot
what's up so
oh i'm already gonna start crying that's
okay that's okay welcome to the gang
thanks
um
i
was in a very abusive relationship um i
got out
out and away and safe
about eight
eight and a half years ago can i stop
you right there for a second
yeah that is still fresh on you
yeah
um we share a child so he's not
he's not completely gone but yeah so
your body has to re-experience that bear
that tiger
every day
yeah and once a week or whatever
drop-off is man i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry thank you what type of
abuse
um
everything
um it started off mental and emotional
um it turned into physical
um
he i mean he would take my money so
there was financial there too
sorry and so i finally got away when he
um
he tried to kill me while i was holding
our daughter
so um wow
i
good for you good for you wow
yeah thank you
so eight years ago and here we are how
can i help today yeah
well
um so he's he's done it again to
somebody else and big shock huh
yeah shocking
uh yeah um but
so
the assault on me when i left was a
strangulation and he strangled this lady
too
and she's come to me for
help she has she also shares a child
with him
um and so it's caused a whole bunch of
you know upheaval
i had filed with the courts to restrict
his parenting time with my daughter so
one of my questions is how to talk to
her about that because she's
confused and misses her brother and
this other mom
and then
the other question i had was how do i
help this mom without re-traumatizing
myself
what a mess
this guy sucks huh
he knows i'm sorry man wow
so
yeah man
unfortunately
i'll answer your second question first
unfortunately i
you i'd stay away from this mess
and
it sounds like you are a person whose
heart
is beating in sync with this other woman
you know what she's been through you
know what the last eight years of your
life have been and nobody walked
alongside him with you and you want to
reach out because you're a good person
you're an empathetic person you love
people
and what i'm gonna tell you is you're
gonna get covered in other people's crap
and there is not a good
winnable solution there's no reason to
participate in this chaos
okay because you found out somebody else
that your husband is not a safe person
that he's got a pattern of physical
violence
um you did the right thing by filing
with the courts that i'm not i don't
want my daughter around that because
it's just a matter of time before she
gets teed up to be the next victim
right
so good for you
but
i would draw a pretty strong hard
boundary between you and what they've
got going on in their crazy world
okay
she needs to
obviously get support she needs to reach
out she needs to get away from that
lunatic and
she needs to file the right restraints
so that she can protect her son
but that's her responsibility not yours
okay
and i know that's hard
and there's something about
purpose and there's something about i
don't say revenge but kind of and
there's something about
finally i'm strong enough eight years
later and now i'm coming back for you
and what i'll tell you is that whole
scenario ends up in everybody in ash
okay
am i right
yeah i mean it kind of feels that way
she um
she's trying to get away and she's
you know contacting me help me help me i
don't know what to do
and
call 911 anytime i would let her know
every time you call me i'm going to call
9-1-1
okay and every time you call me i'm
going to call 9-1-1 and every time you
call me because they are the folks who
can help you i cannot
i'm not going to put myself and my baby
girl in his position of either me being
killed
which he tried before and my daughter
not having a mom anymore and a dad in
prison
i'm not gonna put myself in a situation
where i i don't belong
and the right thing to do when somebody
calls and says i'm being abused and i'm
not safe is i'm going to call 9-1-1
every single time i'll call on my
friends if one of my buddies wives
called me and said hey so-and-so is
beating me up or do i'm calling 9-1-1
i'm getting the police involved
because that's their job
okay and life is not a john wick movie
right right
um as as it relates to talking to your
daughter
how old is she now eight nine
yeah she'll be nine in january okay does
she know anything about your past or
your history or about dad
no he um so
when i left he stayed gone until she was
four okay and
then
had
weekends with him but no overnights
because he was a flight risk and then um
now she's down to
one hour a week at a supervised facility
yeah so
i mean she
she has a context for
my interaction with my dad is different
than my friend's interaction is with
their dads right
yeah have you ever had the conversation
with her that dad is sick
um
we've been teetering on it here
lately yeah
yeah it's time for that conversation and
um
whether you all have a family counselor
that you work with
or
you've got another family friend here's
what i want sometimes when we have a
hard conversation with our kids
they immediately shift into fight or
flight
and because they get there there's kids
grown-ups do it too
but they we shift into they shift into
am i going to be okay
and what did i do
and so often we can have a hard
conversation with our kids and they will
never circle back to us
and ask the follow-up questions
and that's why i'd love to have a either
a counselor or a friend or a
somebody that
not a not a nine-year-old friend but an
adult friend a grown-up friend an aunt
an uncle a cousin somebody that your
daughter trusts
that will loop back and be able to ask
questions
or
you plan for the next two months every
saturday morning i'm going to do
breakfast with her i'm going to move
work around we're going to figure
something out
but i'm going to set up a context
so that we regularly interact with one
another we regularly talk about stuff
together
and eventually those questions will come
up does she feel safe talking with you
about things like that or is a little
bit weird
um i think it's a little bit of both i
last night she came into my room i need
to talk to you
and i've really been working with her
especially here lately on you have to
tell me things
you have to come talk to me it's
important that you feel like it's safe
to come talk to me okay
stop right there stop right there that's
a really important distinction
okay okay
your job as mom
is to create the safe environment
forcing a nine-year-old to talk to you
about something where she doesn't feel
safe
is is is akin to violence
okay it can feel abusive
so when i look at my tenure or my son's
11 if i look at him and say you must
come talk to me
and then i don't create a safe world for
him to come talk to me or where i'm
gonna gonna give him five hours of
lectures or i'm gonna ground him for
talking to me or i'm gonna
make fun of him for whatever
i am forcing him
into an abusive situation
so okay instead of saying you have to
come talk to me
i want you to say
i want to be a safe place for you
maybe i haven't been in the past maybe
i'm gonna continue to work on that
um but you have to tell somebody
and here are two or three people that
are safe for you to talk to your school
counselor aunt jane and me
and i want to give my kids an option i
want them telling somebody
but if their option is
telling an unsafe person which happens
to be me
or
nobody they'll pick nobody and their
bodies will respond for the rest of
their lives
okay okay
so
the best way to do this is to start a
regular breakfast club with your
daughter
dates y'all can get dressed up you can
get dressed down you can only wear
pajamas make it a little bit wonky and a
little bit unique for just y'all
okay
it can be you're gonna get her one piece
of fancy chocolate or ones just
something where it's a little bit
special
and commit on your calendar for the next
two months i'm going to not miss a
saturday
we're going to do this i'm not going to
miss a sunday we're going to use every
single week
and we're just gonna chit chat
what's going on in your world what's
going on in my world what are three
great things i'm gonna bring some
coloring books we may just sit at
cracker barrel and color together and
not say much in anything
she will begin to feel connected to you
and you will hopefully feel not
not say but feel safer
okay and it is time to have the
conversation
the reason your daddy doesn't need to go
into the abuse
but daddy is sick
and daddy can be unsafe
that's why these arrangements are the
way they are
and little brother
little half brother he's gonna be
entering into the same situation soon as
well
he is gonna also be um
moving away because his mommy is not
safe either
not that dad's a bad guy
because your daughter is half dead and
if dad's a bad guy then half of her is a
bad person
it is about dad's actions and dad's
behaviors dad is not well
and sometimes daddy is unsafe
and my one job is making sure you're
safe
and you still love daddy and daddy still
loves you
he just finds himself
unable to control his behavior or
choosing to not control his behavior and
he is unsafe
and any any question i feel like why how
how come it i don't know honey
all i can do is love you
and create a safe space for you
let's get a cinnamon roll right or maybe
not eat cinnamon rolls but whatever it
happens to be
don't force your daughter to
talk about things she doesn't feel safe
about
give her options and create safe
environments for her
create safety
it might be that you have an opportunity
to model for her
and give her a great gift
and teach her how to grieve
he tried to be sad
i'm sad that daddy's not safe
i would love more than anything for you
to be able to run and play with daddy
and it makes me sad
and it's okay to feel sad
and when you teach her that and you give
her permission to feel and you model for
her what feeling feels like what looks
like wow what a gift
what a gift
man she's lucky to have you kayla but
get out of that other mess not your
circus not your circus